[MUSIC]
Hello and welcome everyone.
Good morning, good afternoon, good
evening, wherever you are tuning in from.
Thank you so much for
joining us today for today's panel,
your journey from Stanford
to Latin America.
My name is Jessica Chung,
I'm an admissions officer at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And we're so excited to share a little
bit of what it's like to live and study
at the GSB and the sort of opportunities
that the GSB experience can offer you,
especially if you're interested in
living and working in Latin America.
And I'm joined by an awesome
panel of GSB alumni.
And before I introduce them,
I do want to to set the stage for
what our time together
today will look like.
So today's event will include a brief
introduction to our global community.
I'll then introduce you to our
panelists and ask a few questions
of our panelists before turning over
to the Q&A box for your questions.
Feel free to give the Q&A box a try.
You can let us know where you're
tuning in from and your name.
We love getting a sense of who's
in the room with us today.
And all together we will spend
about 55 minutes together.
So I'm looking at the Q&A box.
Hello, Jose Castillo Yana from Chile.
Hello Paula from Colombia, Luis from Peru,
Sara from Chile, Javier from Mexico.
It's so good to see you all here.
It's really exciting for us to see all
these names from around the world, I think
in some ways that's what the GSB is like,
we have a truly international community.
For example, our community includes 60
regional alumni clubs all over the world.
We have over 30,000 GSB alumni globally.
And part of the GSB experience
is extending your network,
broadening the people in your life and
in your community,
including people with many
different perspectives,
who have experiences and
can bring together all of
those different experiences
in one communities.
That is, I think a great part
of the Stanford GSB experience.
Our community also
includes over 50 clubs and
organizations including regional interest
groups, such as the Africa Business Club,
the Business in India Club, Europe Club,
the Greater China Business Club,
the Latin American Student Association,
and the Middle East and North Africa Club.
So I'd like to next
introduce our panelists.
And I might have them
introduce themselves.
I do know that Alice is running
just a couple minutes late, so
hopefully she will join us soon.
In the meantime, Diego, would you
like to introduce yourself first?
>> Sure.
Hi everyone, my name is Diego Benavides,
I'm class of 2018.
Going down my table,
I did my undergrad at Williams College.
My career was consulting
first in California,
then non-profit in South Africa,
then the GSB.
Post GSB, I founded a non-profit
social enterprise called
Latin American Leadership Academy or LALA,
that is based in Medellin, Colombia, but
with Latin American reach.
>> Awesome, thank you.
Juan Manuel,
would you like to introduce yourself next?
>> Of course.
Hello, everybody,
my name is Juan Manuel Gonzales, and
I graduated from the GSB five years ago.
It's hard to believe that, but time flies.
I went to Texas A&M University for
undergrad.
And then post that I went to consulting,
I actually stayed in consulting
all the way to going to GSB.
And then I went back to consulting for
two years, but then after that,
I decided that it was time for
me to come back to Mexico.
I was in consulting in Texas.
And I returned to Mexico three years ago
to become the CEO Executive Director
of Ensena por Mexico, and
I currently live in Mexico City.
>> Awesome, thank you.
So I think we are still waiting on Alice
to join us, which is completely fine.
Before we dive into questions for
our panel,
I do want to note that today is
just one spot on your journey.
Your journey can continue onward
at myStanford.mba where you
can create a profile and
a personalized dashboard where you can
track your application,
browse courses and clubs at the GSB.
You can find other GSB events and
see more student and alumni stories.
We have a really awesome set of events
next week called application week.
So they're all about
the application process and
helping you get across the finish
line with that application.
I will note one more thing, we also have
a Latin American Fee Waiver Program.
So if you are from Latin America and
you earn the equivalent of
40,000 US dollars per year,
you're eligible to apply to the GSB for
free.
So I do want to highlight that
as an awesome opportunity.
And, Alice, I see you joined us.
Welcome-
>> Yeah-
>> So glad you're able to make it.
>> No, I had a technical problem because
I joined but not as a panelist, so
I could hear you and see you,
and I'm like, I'm here [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH] I'm glad-
>> I managed to crack the problem.
So that was it.
>> Awesome [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you so much for joining us.
Do you want to introduce
yourself to our audience?
>> Sure, so I'm Alice, MBA 2016.
I was actually a classmate
with with Manuel.
I am half Brazilian, half Belgian,
but I currently live in Chile.
I've been living here
ever since I graduated.
Before the MBA, I was in finance,
I did some consulting and
then after the MBA, I sort of made
a career switch into marketing.
And now I'm the chief marketing
officer of a bank in Chile.
So that's briefly my background.
>> Awesome, thank you all.
So I'm going to stop sharing my screen so
you all can see us a little bit better.
And to our attendees,
please feel free to start submitting
your questions in the Q&A box.
You can also upvote other folks' questions
if you see that somebody has asked
a question that you're interested in
the answer to, but I'll start with some of
the questions that, I'll start with a few
warm up questions for our panelists.
So, first, I'm curious,
why did you decide to get an MBA, and
why did you decide specifically
to get a Stanford MBA?
>> Maybe any order?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Any order [LAUGH].
>> Perfect, I'll start.
The main reason why I started to get
an MBA from Stanford was because I
wanted to do also something with
education or social entrepreneurship.
And so I actually discover when I was
doing my research about MBA programs that
Stanford allow you to do an MBA and
a master's in education at the same time.
So I applied to both and
I completed both in 2016.
But that was one of the main reasons
before I even fell in love with
the culture of the school.
But as soon as I started to, even in
the process of the admission process,
I went to go see the school,
and I talked to some alumni.
And I really felt that it was a place
where you could be who you were,
and you really could follow
what you were passionate about.
And that was the main reason,
my love for education and management.
And then the culture and
the people at the school.
>> Excellent, thank you for that.
>> Should I go next?
Is that okay?
>> Sure.
>> So for me, first of all,
I wanted to do an MBA also because I sort
of felt trapped in
the finance consulting world,
and I really wanted to make
a change in my career.
And so that was one of the main reasons
that I started thinking about doing MBA.
And then why Stanford,
I was really drawn by the opportunities,
not only at the GSB, but
also outside of the GSB.
So, specifically for me, the engineering
school, so the design school,
the engineering school.
I took many classes at the engineering
school and I found those really,
really enriching to the whole
business experience as well.
And other than that,
obviously the weather [LAUGH], and
the good climate like living in Chile.
It's sort of the same
climate in Palo Alto.
So that was really, really nice.
And I was always laughing with my friends
that were at Harvard, for example,
who had really cold winters and
we were at the swimming pool in February.
So that was really, really nice.
>> My reasons were somewhat similar to
Juan's ones, but slightly different.
So I was in South Africa, I had been
outside of Latin America maybe ten years.
I had been working in nonprofits so
I had no savings.
And I had very few networks,
almost nothing in Latin America.
And I wanted to embark on this journey to
launch a continental social enterprise,
which is way out of proportion for
what I could do at the time.
So for me, going to the GSB for
a couple of years to give myself time
to develop the idea, develop myself,
build networks, was really valuable.
Also because the program that I wanted
to build was focused on leadership and
from my read of different MBA programs.
I almost saw the GSB as more of
a leadership masters than a traditional
business masters, and it seemed like
it was the best one in the world.
So I wanted to see from within what was so
good about it to get inspired.
But, I mean, both to build up myself and
to become inspired for
what we could build in Latin America.
So yeah, those are a couple of
the biggest reasons for me.
>> Awesome, thank you all for
sharing that.
My next question is, I'm wondering
what were some of the courses,
experiences, or resources that you
leveraged in pursuing your careers,
especially as they relate to
pursuing a career in Latin America?
What were some of the opportunities
at the GSB that helped you with that?
>> I don't know if Juan wants to start.
But for me, most importantly the network,
given that there are not that many
Latin American students at the GSB.
I mean, there are quite a few,
but you end up knowing them all.
And so it's really,
really easy to build that bridge.
So my husband is also a GSB alum and
recently he was looking for
a country manager for
his company in Mexico.
And through the GSB network,
he turned out to find one.
So actually it's been really useful,
and that I think is
the foremost important thing of a Stanford
network, and it's very closely knit.
So it's really easy to
reach out to someone.
You really know the person,
it's not a large class.
You end up knowing maybe 80,
85% of your class, you really know them.
So it's really good.
And then the second thing I would say,
for me, the most instrumental class so
far is still Touchy Feely or
interpersonal dynamics.
I think that's a class
that I still use daily.
I actually recently bought the book
that came our of the course, and
really helped me [INAUDIBLE] and
remember all the concepts and
all the learnings that
I had from that class.
But I would say, for me,
still the most valuable class, and
it sounds cliche because most of
alums say that, but it's really true.
>> Yeah, I will mention,
in my case I knew I had, similar to Diego,
I had actually ten years in
the United States before starting the GSB.
And I knew I wanted to
return to Latin America.
So a lot of my GSB
experiences were around that.
So I did a GMIX in Paraguay.
My GSB was in Chile.
And then I led a GST to Panama and
Honduras.
So I knew that I wanted to make
sure that I had the knowledge of
the business culture.
Anything that I needed to do in
Latin America because most of
my professional life I had
been in the United States.
So I took advantage of those two years
to make sure that I reconnected with
Latin America.
And I also would like to highlight
what Alice said, is the network.
I pretty much know all of
the Latin American people in my class and
you get to meet the ones above,
the ones below.
But in particular, since I knew
that I wanted to return to Mexico,
I took the time to create and
build those strong relationships.
And most of my job that I do
right now is fundraising.
And thanks to the network of the GSB,
I'm able to achieve the goals that I
need to do for fundraising and
teach for Mexico.
So I definitely see it as a place
where you will create these
awesome relationships
that are very intimate.
So whenever you would reach out to them,
they'll say yes to whatever
you're asking of them.
So those are the things that
I would like to highlight.
Excellent, and just for our audience,
there were a couple of
acronyms you threw out there.
So GMIX, and I think GST.
>> Global Management Immersion Experience,
which is for
four weeks you get to go and work in
a country where you have never worked.
And a GST, a global study trip.
The one that I did in Chile
was as a participant.
So it's a trip in which you go for
a full week to talk to business people,
to people from the cultural aspect
to actually know what it's like do
business in that country.
And you also, as a second year,
you can lead a trips.
And it is awesome because you
get to talk to express events,
quorum president when you look
into organize this meetings.
But I definitely recommend them
because it truly allows you to see,
even though it's only seven or eight days.
We'd really pack those experiences and
I definitely recommend them.
>> Excellent, thank you.
>> I don't think I took any classes
that were focused on Latin America.
I would definitely echo
the The alumni network, professors
are more than an admissions
officer told me that
they were the most underutilized
assets at the GSB.
Most professors there are top of
their industry, their total badasses.
So, professors alarms,
almost like any class that
touches on interpersonal skills,
communication skills,
relationship building,
all of that ended up being super
helpful to build my own networks.
And for me also the entrepreneurship
classes like startup
garage really helped me
shift my internal chip from.
I have this idea that I want to
build in the world to a more lean
startup design thinking approach.
I was a lot more humble,
a lot more experimental,
a lot more listening, involved.
But I think ultimately ended up
lobbying land American leadership
academy being a much more innovative,
leaner,
scalable venture than it would have been
without me internalizing these ideas.
And I'm also writing in
the chat room these classes.
>> Awesome, thank you.
Thank you all so much for
your reflections so far.
There is a question in the chat
that I want to elevate.
So one of our attendees asks, how would
you describe the GSB community and
culture?
I think it's interesting that, I think
all three of you reflected on community,
network, on one way and while I think you
use the word like intimate community.
I am wondering what is it about the GSB,
the community or
the culture that creates
the sense of closeness.
And this willingness to help other
folks in the GSB community and network.
>> I will start by, so go ahead, Alice.
>> Well, go.
>> I will start by saying that,
I think the GSB does a very good
job on identifying very good,
well rounded human beings.
That are trying to really live through
the modal of the GSB, change lives,
change organizations,
and change the world.
So I think what allowed me to connect with
many of my classmates why's that even
though we might not have shared
the similar passion, in my case,
it was education,
what I'm passionate about.
We were so truly passionate
about something in particular or
to make the world a better place,
not just to make ourselves better or
just to feel our ego.
It was more like that and then he also
held that the class size is not so big.
So, I mean, I pretty much throughout
the two years I definitely
can identify every single
classmate by face and name.
Maybe of course I would like if I tell you
that I developed friendships with the 400.
But it would about 200 of them I
definitely created some connections.
And then if we go to smaller,
like about 10, 15 of them,
they'll continue to be
some of my closest people.
That I tell even to this day that I
message that we have some calls that
we organize trips.
And it has to do with that aspect that I
think we are truly there to find things or
tools that are going to help
us to improve the world.
And that is even though you
might be in a different area,
we share that passion to make
the world a better place.
>> I would say just add to that I
fully agree with what he says I think,
just add to that.
I think the location also helps the fact
that you're not in the middle of a big
city, you're close to San Francisco, but
you're like 45 minutes away an hour away.
So, and sort of that, sort of really,
maybe we used to joke that there was this
magnetic thing around the Stanford campus.
That didn't allow you to get out of
it because you feel so attracted and
just everything you need is there.
And so it really generates this
not only with the GSB students but
also you end up getting to know.
For example, I lived in Escondido
village which is like the family place,
and I really got to know my neighbors.
And until this day I still have contact
with most of them and so I would say that
makes it like sort of a really tight
community, I think location really helps.
because I've seen I've visited other
locations and other schools that you have
this if it's inserted in the city,
it's less community, right?
So I think that helps as well.
>> Super quickly I'd say there
seem to be genuine care for
each other's development.
So people talk about culture feedback,
big cultural vulnerability,
like for
a lot of people it's kind of weird.
So, but it can be beautiful so
make sure that you're comfortable
entering a space where people
will be digging into emotions and
feelings, and
be very curious to talk about that a lot.
And, yeah, I would echo what one must
say that I think a higher than average
percentage of people who really want to
make a difference in the world.
>> Lesson, thank you all.
Yeah, I have heard before
I think got another panel,
somebody said that it wasn't
unusual to see a classmate cry,
maybe like once or twice a week.
And, [LAUGH] maybe that's
not true of your experience,
maybe it's just only
true of her experience.
And I think some of that starts not the
crying necessarily, but being vulnerable,
trying to sort of figure out how to
express your authentic self kind of
starts in the application process.
Like one of our essay questions is
what matters most to you and why?
And I've heard from so many students
an alumni that process of reflecting and
that process of introspection kind of
starts with the application process.
So, I'm turning back to the Q&A box and
thank you to our attendees who
are submitting really fabulous questions.
I may see that there are a couple
questions about MSX and
I'm going to differ to
the MSX admissions team if
you have questions about
their admissions process.
I defer to them please feel
free to reach out to them.
But there was one question about intending
to stay in the US after the program and
wondering if they would be able to
find work opportunities in the US.
Juan Manuel, you mentioned
that you stayed in the US for
a period of time after getting your MBA.
Can you say a little bit about
what that process was like,
any support or resources that
you found helpful at the GSB?
>> Yeah, I think many of my classmates
even some of my Mexican classmates,
like half there were nine of us and
half of us were staying in the United
States for one or two years after the GSB.
And of course there is the support of
helping you get a job with these places
that are going to get you the visa to
be able to stay in the United States.
So there is definitely support also from
the Career Center if you need advice or
what is the process to be able to stay.
But there is opportunity and like I
have even some of them are still there,
so you want to stay a bit longer.
But of course me being an advocate for
Latin America, I want you to come back.
Don't stay in in the United States for
too long.
Something that I would
like to highlight is by so
the question about
the return on investment.
Definitely, I think that our talent,
having the privilege of going to the GSB
is way more valuable than in Latin America
than if you stay in the United States.
There is many more GSB
years in the United States.
If you come here,
you are the top of the top.
So you're going to be able to get those
positions that are very well paid.
So the return will be there but like me,
I'm deviating from the question.
But I am a person that spent
14 years in the United States,
but I can tell you that our
talent is more needed here than
there's a place if you stay only there for
a few years and
then come back and
do something for our countries.
>> I think also I have
a Commonwealth to that point.
I think, well I know for the Brazilians
because I was really good friends with
all of them and like I would say,
only two of them have stayed.
Most of them stayed a few years after and
then most of them are back in Brazil now
and then two of them have stayed and
that's maybe because they married with
Americans or with other internationals.
And I would say as well for the Chileans,
I think the three of the Chileans well,
two of them well, one is back now
in the US, but he came back for
a long time he did entrepreneurship and
then he went back.
So I would say most of them,
at some point come back.
So, I think it's because you get more
opportunities here than perhaps in the US,
but not for everyone.
There's cases that get a lot of
opportunities in the US as well.
So I think it's a personal journey.
>> So, thank you both.
There's a question that
I think picks up on some
of the themes that you
all are drawing out.
Jose asks, how has the GSB community
supported your career success?
And I want manual, well,
you brought up the other question
earlier about return on investment and
the access to distinctive opportunities
that you might only find at the GSB.
So, yeah, how is the GSB community,
even after you've graduated continue
to support your career success?
>> Let Diego start with this one because
I feel like I'm a little stubborn.
>> [LAUGH]
>> For me, it's been hugely valuable.
I mean, I'm sure there may have been
other ways to get connected but
for example, our main funder we met
because of our professors introduction.
Another main funder was a professor.
The first foundation that supported
us was an introduction by a professor.
Then the first Latin American
donors we found have mostly been
somehow connected to the GSB.
So all that had been super helpful.
Also, I mean other introductions not
just donor connected have happened
faster through GSB alumni for sure.
Maybe it's in part because the, I mean,
it's not a large community, right, like so
definitely other MBAs will have larger
alumni communities in Latin America.
I don't know if they
would be as responsive.
I would just go to
the rain processions and
ask them in my case,
it has been fairly responsive.
Not everyone, but most.
So,
>> In my case,
I'm, I won't say that the community
has helped me directly,
I would say indirectly because I've had,
they helped me with top processes,
like what change should I make now?
But I think I've made some pretty big
switches in my career, even after the MBA.
So I started at AB InBev
in their ZX ventures,
which is their new product development or
how you want to call it.
Then I switched,
I became the CMO of a tech startup and
have knowing nothing about tech and
I have never worked in tech.
And I became the CMO of a tech startup.
And I think part of the reason I
could make that change was because of
the Stanford credibility and
the fact that Stanford has a lot,
has a focus on tech and knows a lot about,
you get this entrepreneurship classes and
all these vibes when you're there.
And I think that's the main
reason that I was able to
actually make that switch that fast.
So I think it gives you credibility.
And that really helps during your career,
especially if you want to
make some different changes.
And then the community
helps in different ways.
For example, for them,
it was fundraising for me.
It's more like opening opportunities and
helping think through what should
be my next move in my career.
And that really has helped me getting,
having that support network
to talk about those things.
>> I don't have anything else to add.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So we can take more questions.
>> All right, thank you.
There are a bunch of
great questions in here.
There are a couple that, okay,
I'm going to bring together a couple
questions that are in here.
A few of our attendees are wondering
what was your most memorable
experience during the,
during your MBA experience?
So most memorable experience or
the most valuable impact on you,
personally and
professionally from your MBA experience.
>> Most memorable I'll say TALK.
TALK is a tradition at the GSB.
Where every Monday or Wednesday depending
on the class that you are a there
whether your first or second year.
Classmates share their life story.
And it can be about
anything that they decide.
And for me, I was able to share
what I can from, my love for
education and everything.
And remembering, seen so many people just
curious to know who I was as a person.
And then also thinking of the other side,
listening to all the stories
of my classmates.
And it makes you realize how human we
are of course we are all human but
when you go to those talks you,
people that you've never expected to
have gone through very hard challenges.
They actually went through very difficult
challenges, people that you never knew
that were very good at a certain sport or
very good about a certain subject.
That is the most memorable.
And the most impact is
definitely I will also
highlight what it was has
been said about leadership.
One class that has had the most
impact in my career and
since I started out in Singapore, Michigan
has been managing growing enterprise.
By this class, I never thought that I will
have to deal with writing a press release.
I never thought that I will have to
deal with drama between founders and
board members.
I never thought many things at this class.
I learned,
now I'm looking back in retrospect and
be Literally,
they teach you many of the pain
points of a growing enterprise and
prepare you for
what you're going to be facing
as a leader of an organization.
>> Yeah, my most memorable experience is,
I did an exchange with
the Tsinghua University in China.
And I have never been to China and
I think we went there and
I think it was in October or November.
It was really, really cold and
I ended up having a bronchitis and
I ended up in the hospital in China,
it was crazy.
But that experience was for me and
studying at the University of Tsinghua.
Doing that was also really,
really impactful for me.
And then when the Tsinghua students
came back to Stanford, and
we got to like, they stayed at our houses,
it was a really cool program.
I really enjoyed that.
And then personally, I think another
really memorable experience for me was
just, I went to the GSB with my daughter,
so she was three when we got to the GSB.
And it was just me and her and I think,
yeah, we spent two years there and
seeing her grow up and I mean grew up
because she was five when we left but
grow through that process and
living there with her.
And seeing her really involved in the
Stanford GSB life was really impactful.
And to this day, I think it really had
a major impact on her and her development.
So yeah.
>> That's beautiful.
Thanks for sharing.
>> For me,
I remember it wasn't just one moment,
but I remember being struck by
how consistent the theories,
the philosophies, the evidence were,
all in the direction of
a particular kind of leadership.
Fortunately, was connected
to just be a better person.
Listen, be humble.
Try to do what's best for
your team, your customers.
When you're negotiating,
it's not about crushing.
It's about finding a creative win win for
both parties and so on.
I think only one class talked more about,
by the way,
don't forget about power and
it's a classical path to power.
That is kind of like
the dark side of class but
everything else was very much aligned.
And for me, that was helpful because
there's so many books out there, so
many gurus, so many podcasts and articles.
That, for me,
the consistency from very successful,
very thoughtful people
backed also by research
that there is this consistent narrative.
It just helped me cut through so
much noise.
And echoing what Pamela was saying,
I found that the hardest
challenges in this line of work have
been interpersonal and intrapersonal.
So I've enjoyed the GSB's emphasis, but
there's a lot of classes
you can take on both.
I wouldn't say there's just
like the one class and
those have been the most
impactful post GSB.
>> Awesome, thank you all for
sharing those reflections.
There are a few questions as well about
what surprised you all about the GSB?
What did you maybe not know that
you learned during your time?
Or what did you not know about the GSB
that you learned during your time there?
Yeah, let's start there.
What surprised you about the GSB?
Or even something that you wish you
had known prior to your experience.
>> I said it earlier but
I wish I had known just the caliber
of some of the professors.
Yeah, I mean, there's just so
much wisdom and,
networks and
resources behind each one of them.
And if you try to get to know
them outside of the GSB,
there's 1000 steps you
have to get through.
At GSB you can just take their class, you
can take them out for coffee and so on.
So just investing a little bit more time
not just reading the class reviews, or
not just reading the class description but
also trying to be like,
who are these professors?
And trying to build those personal
connections with them and
that they are responsive.
They will grab coffee with you,
if you're their students, mostly.
I found that surprising and I wish I had
be even more intentional about that and
carved more time for that.
>> I wish I will have known how intense
it is, because I mean we are talking from
the place that we finish and
we love it and everything.
But be prepared for a place where if
you want to make your experience more
enjoyable, it took me the first
quarter to realize that.
You cannot do everything,
all the opportunities out there.
The classes can be challenging
if you make them challenging.
The social events, everything
is like a place where I mean for
me helped me that I did know what
I wanted to do post the GSB.
However, I recommend you
that get some ideas for
what you want to get out of it because if
not, you're going to confront yourself
with many opportunities and you're not
going to be able to do all of them.
So, you're going to get anxiety,
stress and and all of that.
So I wish I would have known that.
You need to get there with more like
a focus otherwise it can be stressful.
>> I think from you, and
the thing that most surprised me, and
they say it very graphically at Stanford
in the beginning, is that we're all ducks.
We look calm on the surface, but
under the water we're all like
paddling really, really fast.
And I think what most surprised me there
was that first quarter I struggled a lot,
just as especially with my daughter and
dealing with all
the intellectual challenge.
I would get home and actually be happy
to be able to talk to people for
two hours, not having said anything smart.
And I think that once you
realize that everyone's in
the same boat,
most people are paddling under water.
You sort of relax and I think that's
the thing that most surprised me,
realizing that most people were actually
the same and I think that surprised me.
>> Thank you for that.
I guess, Diego, you kind of touched on
what you would have done differently based
on what you know now.
Juan Manuel and an Alice is there anything
that you would have done differently
based on some of those things that
surprised you about the GSB or otherwise?
>> I only started taking courses
outside of the GSB in the second year.
I maybe would have done it one quarter
earlier because I really like engineering
and coding and things like that,
and so I ended up not being
able to do one coding
class that I wanted to do.
But I think that's the only thing
that I would have done differently,
like look outside of the box.
It really, he makes sure that I'm
taking in all of the Stanford
because the GSB is immersed in a bigger
Stanford campus that I want to.
That's the one thing that I think
I would have done differently.
>> If you know I'm going to echo
what Diego say about professors,
I didn't develop.
Any strong relationships with professors,
I focus more on classmates.
So looking back and talking to some
classmates that are very good friends,
with professors even after
they have graduated.
I wish that I will have identified
there is only a couple that I can still
keep in touch, but
I talked to some of my classmates that
are live with five different professors.
And they went Go have coffee still or
when they Professor comes
to Mexico they hang out.
So I wish I will have taken
advantage of that great resource.
That is the professors at the GSB.
>> Thanks, thank you all for
sharing those reflections.
We have a couple questions
about leadership style as well.
Some of our attendees are curious how your
leadership style changed
due to your experience
at the GSB as well as how
did that affects your.
I mean, how did that affect your
leadership in this very unprecedented
time and COVID if it did
>> Now,
I would say for me, I mean,
I think it did affect my leadership style.
I think before that I didn't really
have that much leadership experience.
Like I was in consulting,
I was still like a senior analyst.
So I was just meeting two or three people.
And then after that,
I really felt like I was ready to
get more to lead bigger teams.
I think the most important thing for
me like takeaway from GSB has
been to really meet people where
they are like understand that you
have different persons in your team.
And they all did want different things and
really try to understand whether their
personal motivations,
what is really important to them.
Try to, like really meet their
development where they want to go and
give them those that those challenges
that they really are interested in.
Because if they're internally motivated,
they are much more productive, and
you don't need to worry about
retaining them about like pay.
Well, you still need to worry about that,
obviously, but I mean, it's easier.
It's just much easier, and
you build a better team.
Also, the other thing I think I would
say is one of the classes I had I don't
remember which one.
But it talks about If you're going to
make changes in your team, and
I'm talking about when you take on
a new team, when you change jobs,
make them once, and
cut deep, and cut once.
I think that was what they said, I think
it was managing growing enterprise.
I don't remember which wish it was, but I
think that's one of the takeaways I've had
as well, like when you have
to make difficult decisions.
Make them once and make them so
that you don't mess up the team so
that people don't start worrying like
okay, how am I going to be next?
Is it is this it or not?
So I think that's been
one of my big takeaways.
And I would say in COVID that helped, to
a certain extent, were in my previous job.
At the end of my previous job,
we had to let go some people, so
I would say that was really useful and
post COVID.
I think one of the things that really
helps me now is that I try to innovate
when I do meetings with my team.
Like let's not use teams.
Again, let's not use Zoom again,
let's use this other app that we can do or
let's do something different.
I send them coffees I do.
And I think that constant innovation is
something that I really got from Stanford.
>> That's awesome.
>> For me, it has been,
I want it to be perfect before the GSB for
everything that I do
when I was in consulting.
And I worry too much
about these perfection.
And after the GASB in a more
like emotional perfection,
never showing if I was
breaking in siren anything.
For the GSB that has changed a lot and
definitely more
bigger I've noticed on notice
get to ask for n COVID.
These became so high in the education
sector in communities where
we work without asking for
help to my own teams to my board.
To tell them I need more money like I'm
like the organization is in danger,
so being able to express yourself and
be vulnerable.
For me, it has been how my leadership
style has changed a lot and
is in similar to Elise, I know that
people also have their vulnerabilities.
And if they see the leader opening up,
you're going to know what is happening
behind their mind, and he's going to help
you to identify how can you support them.
To even become better at their job,
so definitely that's the way
that the GSB changed me and
was like it's okay to be vulnerable.
It's okay to show your emotions.
And I'm not afraid anymore even if
people some people that are like
me like I was before that
thought are showing emotions.
Maybe it was a sign of weakness, I don't
care because maybe that's not the type of
leader that I want to create
a strong relationship.
So I want to create relationships with
people that are truly vulnerable and
humane.
So that has helped me a lot
to create even like now.
Very good partnerships in the organization
because we connect with those people.
>> I love all those points.
Also, I thinking that I think a lot of
what happens at the GSV's that you get
exposed to a lot of these ideas.
Tools [INAUDIBLE] you just have to keep
practicing then the rest of your life,
like snap, not going to come out.
I was like,
just I know kung fu like he was going to
you know have to keep practicing.
For example, like a lot of the emotion
like connecting with your emotion's
vulnerability, compassion,
self compassion.
Pre GSB I was definitely very much
up here like post consulting,
econ undergrad like a very analytical and
I think I started opening
up more to these things.
I think it helped me on the communication
side when pitching Lyla I remember
getting the feedback those like I'm
hearing that you're excited about this.
But you're speaking like a consultant,
that's a good point.
So when I'm talking about lol I will lead
more of the emotion commands compassion.
And self compassion super valuable
especially over the last few years both
with myself and the team and
students and so on.
So some both of those
they've definitely helped.
I forget from which classes but at the
beginning of the pandemic we had to make
a really hard choice around do we close
the program and fly all the students home.
Do we keep them and hedge our bets since
one and remember this idea of like at
the end of the day if you're in
a leadership position you have to make
the final call you have to be decisive
kind of like what I was saying.
But it's something you just have
to be decisive, make the call.
But you can be inclusive,
you can listen and include others.
So remember,
we set ourselves up 24 hours Timeline, so
we're going to listen to the students,
the parents, the team, donors,
advisors, everyone, but
this time tomorrow we're making the call.
In hindsight,
that probably saved us from bankruptcy.
[LAUGH] And then this connected to
leadership and entrepreneurship,
I think I really came out of the GSB
having adopted the DNA of lean startup,
experimentation, trial and
error, prototyping,
also of empowering the team
to be the innovators.
And I think we have come
out of the pandemic, but
we are still in the pandemic, but
we're stronger now than before.
We have virtual programs that
we had never considered before,
a lot of that are team innovations.
So, but being very comfortable
with trying new things,
experimenting, being comfortable
with some things not working out.
And again, empowering the team
to speak up, take ownership,
innovate, collectively I think
over time lead to stronger teams,
better organizations as well.
Yeah, I think I credit
the GSB with a lot of that.
>> Awesome, thank you.
I think we have time for
maybe one more question and
bringing together a couple
questions that I see in the Q&A.
A couple of our attendees are wondering,
when is the right time?
How did you all know that it was
the right time to pursue an MBA?
If you did know or
did you take the plunge not knowing?
How did you know you were ready for
the experience?
>> I think for me it was about,
I had to juggle two things,
is it the right moment for me?
Is it right moment for
my daughter and for me?
It just coincided that I applied and
I got to just be at the average age,
which is 27 or 28,
I entered the GSB when I was 28.
But I started working when I was 22, so
I already had six years of experience, and
it just coincided with my daughter
still being in preschool.
[LAUGH] So for me that was important
because I wanted her to be in elementary
school right away where she was going to
be the whole elementary school.
So those two things combined,
having enough experience.
I had a few classmates who
were just out of undergrad and
maybe have taken one or two years off.
And they had undoubtedly had also
a very good experience, but I remember
them telling me, few of them telling me,
I wish I'd come a little later.
So I could bring more to the class,
so I could give more back,
because I feel like I'm only getting and
I'm not returning.
And I think that is sort of true.
I think you sort of need
a certain amount of not years, but
a certain amount of experience to
really be able to contribute to
the discussion that
goes on in every class.
>> For me, [LAUGH] I remember I was
ready to submit my application and
then I asked myself, okay, why the GSB?
Why an MBA?
Why the GSB?
When I asked why now,
I didn't have a good answer for myself.
I had done two years of consulting,
two years at a nonprofit.
And I don't know why I had this idea of
two plus two plus two was a good idea,
right?
I was like if I leave this nonprofit now,
when I graduate from the MBA,
I will be under 30 with an MBA.
For some reason,
that's a good thing to be.
[LAUGH] And for me, a couple of things
pushed me to wait one more year.
One was that at this nonprofit,
I had built two years of knowledge,
insight skills, social capital.
So, I felt like I could give more to that
nonprofit if I stayed there one more year,
third year instead of just leaving.
And two, I didn't have almost
any managerial experience.
So I tried to make sure I had that for
at least one year pre-MBA.
I was at the GSB ages 28, 30, so
I was on the slightly older side.
I feel I got a lot more out of
it than if I had gone earlier.
Even now, after three years running,
I'm like, I wish I could go now.
[LAUGH] I feel like I would get so
much more now just because, I don't know,
you go through a class that touches on
hiring or a class that touches on firing.
And now three years later,
I'm like, what did we cover?
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Maybe I should have been a better
student, yeah.
>> In my case it was,
I guess, I'm the spectrum,
I applied when I was 23 to the GSB.
So I was one of the young ones,
but I started working at 20.
In consultants,
I had three years of experience.
For me, it was a sense of urgency
to wanting to do something for
education in Latin America and
coming back.
I grew up in a low socioeconomic
status of Mexico and
coming back that people were
getting involved in crime,
there was a lot of corruption.
It was very unsafe to live in
the neighborhood that I was in.
I was like, why am I the lucky one
living in Houston, having a great life.
And that's when I was like I
need to find a way to speak,
how can I get to a education
leadership position pastor?
And identify that getting an MBA
at a top business school,
combining with the education
knowledge will get me there faster.
So that's what took me, and I knew it was
the right time because the problems that I
was seeing in Mexico could not wait.
So I was like, I need to make this quick,
so that's when I decided to apply.
I got accepted when I was 22, I started
when I was 24, and I don't regret it.
I definitely felt that I learned a lot,
but again,
I come from this idea that I wanted
to make things happen faster.
And it really helped me because
I don't think without the GSB,
I will have become the executive
director of a nonprofit.
Besides that, Mexico was when I joined
two years and a half, two years ago.
>> Awesome, thank you all so
much for your candor, for
sharing so
much of your journeys with our audience.
I will note regarding the question
about how do you decide when to apply?
Our community includes people with
a wide range of experiences and
that includes years of work experience.
As Alice mentioned, some folks might
have a couple years of experience,
some folks might have over
a decade of experience,
and all are welcome in
our application process.
And we think that all of
those experiences bring
a perspective that enriches
our educational environment.
So thank you all again for
sharing your perspectives with us.
For attendees,
we're going to throw a poll out there, so
you can let us know how we're doing.
These events are all about serving you, so
we would love to get some of your feedback
about how this event has gone for you all.
And thank you, again, for spending
a little bit of your day with us and
take care.
Thank you all so much.
[MUSIC]